have i not seen you since i got sober
yeah it's been some years yeah dude
[ __ ] years i've been sober 13 years
congratulations on dad thank you so much
man
yeah you were privy to what a pile i was
was the last time you guys saw each
other at the rainbow room yeah it
probably would have been drinking at the
bar i i think i dropped him off at the
apartment you were staying at at the
time we got off actually i went with you
into the apartment something was going
on and then you rammed your [ __ ] head
through the [ __ ]
through the drywall i was like
at the apartment yeah oh what do you
mean like the night like that was
we with the guy named stomper i think so
yeah
right be real had the best friends man
they got these guys they're the stomper
and uh
guitar big marv there's a big mom
how's he doing uh he's good he's slimmed
down he's you know he's he's uh toned
his party life down a little bit
because he's a little bit older and you
know
you can't you can't grind all the time
every [ __ ] day like these guys were
but yeah he's doing all right he's doing
all right you guys hung out quite a bit
back in the day yeah our spot was the
rainbow yeah and so like
and this was before marijuana was like
legal it was like kind of [ __ ] up to
just sit down at a restaurant and be
rolling joints and smoking them on the
patio and right and and it was just cool
there
yeah we made it like little amsterdam
yeah you know i was tight with the owner
mario rest in peace mario maglia a
legend on sunset strip
and uh his family owns the rainbow the
whiskey in various places um
and when i got there i was introduced to
him by this this guy named big worm rest
in peace who just passed away you've
participated
yeah he passed away recently he got out
of prison and
maybe
six months later he passed away but i
got to see him before uh before he
passed um but mario allowed us
to be on the patio
smoking weed he got a kick out of it he
didn't he didn't smoke himself he didn't
do any of the drugs he just maybe had a
drink but he allowed everybody there to
be themselves and and do what they do as
long as they didn't act like [ __ ]
get in fights and [ __ ] like that which
did happen but
you know we kept it together when we
were out there it was more about just
hanging yeah and and having a good time
yeah i remember um one time you you had
a bit like a big boombox cd player on
the table and you played for me
psycho realm yeah and uh that [ __ ] was
so dope i stole your your cd man
that's all right i left with that
mixtape that night
i had many more dude
that [ __ ] was great man shout out to
psycho realm man sick jacking yeah that
was your first time hearing it i
remember because you know we had i think
we had put that album out in 97
and it had been around for a while but
we were talking about it
and then i just brought it and and you
got a chance to hear it and you took it
and that was good
because that's what that's what it's
about us is artists keeping cds it never
happens yeah you know what i mean we
want someone i think you might have left
it like
on the table and then i was like oh
that's mine yeah yeah yeah you coke off
this later
or chuck it at somebody yeah oh man i do
know i cherish that thing man to to this
day i i love those guys it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude